Speaker 1: Before we move on, just real quick.
It's becoming pretty damn clear that radical,
repugnant, reactionary and rancid Republican
Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor GREENE wants to be
Donald Trump's running mate in 2024. If he were to
be the Republican nominee and I have to tell you,
I don't think it's completely out of the
question that Trump would consider her.
Here is Marjorie Taylor. GREENE over the weekend
on Real America's Voice Turning Point USA.
Whatever, it's hard to even keep
track of what these appearances are
and hear. She plays coy, but says
she would be honored to be Donald
Trump's running mate. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: All right. So what do you do with
the fact that as people are starting to look
forward to 2024, I think there's consensus
mostly among our audience anyway. And with most
of the people that I've spoken with here, that
Donald Trump needs to be the nominee and anybody
else is sort of a distraction at this point. At
least that's what I'm hearing from people. But
that I hear the words empty. She mentioned a lot.
Speaker 3: Hello.
Speaker 2: As somebody who
be a great running mate for Donald Trump,
I just wonder, what will you do with that?
Well, I you know what? I think if he asked
me, I would definitely give that some strong
consideration. I love President Trump. I never
I never hide that fact. I think he's wonderful.
Speaker 1: That's not a secret, folks.
Speaker 2: I have a great relationship
with him. I talk to him frequently. I'm I'm so
thankful for him and his family, as we all are.
And I defend him all the time.
Speaker 1: I every night.
I get down on my knees and I pray
about how thankful I am that Eric
Trump became a much more well-known figure.
Speaker 2: I swear, I would I would fight for
that man because he fought for us. And that's the
kind of president we need back. And if if if he
were to ask me, of course, I would be honored.
Speaker 1: It would be an honor for Marjorie
Taylor GREENE. So it's way too early to really
be talking about this. It's it's just so early.
But I don't think this is as crazy or unlikely
as some might think. I'm not saying MTG
is the likeliest running mate for Trump, but she
is the type of endlessly brown nosing sycophant
that Donald Trump wants around him, much more
so than Mike Pence. And so let's just not
laugh it into the toilet and flush it 10 to 15
times the way it should be as an idea just yet,
because Trump has done and said much crazier
things than considering Marjorie Taylor GREENE
for his running mate. Let's hope it doesn't
happen. Let me know your thoughts. Find me
on Twitter at David Pakman. We will take a
break and be right back. The David Pakman
Show is a viewer and listener supported program
funded primarily by the bonus show. Yeah.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show where you want to
make money and everybody else that makes money to
fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Well, I'm not the one
facing a defamation suit, Alex, and we'll
talk about that later. You can sign up at
join Packman dot com. Use the coupon code. Big
voting 22. All one word, all lowercase. To get a
massive discount off of the
cost of your membership.
Speaker 3: That is a frickin predator right there.
Speaker 1: It's actually just a great deal.